WENWU
Throughout my life...
...the Ten Rings
gave our family power.
If you want them
to be yours one day,
you have to show me
you're strong enough to carry them.
♪♪
YING NAN
You are a product of all
who came before you.
The legacy of your family.
You are your mother.
And whether you like it or not...
...you are also your father.
♪♪
WENWU
I told my men...
...they wouldn't be able to
to kill you if they tried.
WENWU
Glad I was right.
♪♪
SHANG-CHI
You're just a criminal who murders people.
WENWU
Be careful how you speak to me, boy.
♪♪
SHANG-CHI
I thought I could change my name,
...start a new life.
But I could never escape his shadow.
WENWU
My son...
You can't run from your past.
SHANG-CHI
Is this what you wanted?
♪♪
KATY
You got this.
ABOMINATION
[Roars]
SHANG-CHI
Thank you.